[Music]
last month U.S President Joe Biden
announced he was running for re-election
in a Snappy video that is commonplace in
political advertising that's why I'm
running for reelection this just did
moments later the Republican Party
released its own video depicting a
terrifying yet hypothetical World should
Biden be re-elected
[Music]
[Applause]
one but it's all fake entirely created
by artificial intelligence Hills closed
the city of San Francisco this morning
citing the escalating time and National
crisis it could be a signal of what's to
come and dangers AI pose it used to be
the case that you could you know look up
some of the truth of an article or a
truth of a claim based on what sort of
images were there at the scene now those
images can be fabricated as well so it's
quite possible for voters to be
significantly misled about different
candidates in our time right now we
shape the AI of tomorrow while AI is
mostly being tested in the United States
Mitchell says that could change quickly
thank you with wide-ranging
ramifications the ability of these
systems to make things up and persuade
manipulate people is a really really big
concern that I think people around the
world should be aware of in in upcoming
elections because now this technology is
massively available including to
governments that might have might have
interest in messing up different
different elections
the U.S about to enter a new election
cycle AI generated political video
content is expected to grow more rampant
online
now Congress is trying to figure out how
to regulate it representative Yvette
Clark a Democrat from here in New York
has introduced a bill that would require
any political advertising that uses
artificial intelligence to clearly
reveal and disclose that to voters it's
unclear how much support this bill has
in Congress or if or when it will ever
be voted on it's clear now more than
ever AI is not just a discussion of what
might be but what is
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York